to keep the bucket bite the dust cash in
your chips
check out the part expire launch into
eternity these are all youthful isms we
use in humor to describe the one life
event we are all going to experience
death but most of us don't want to
acknowledge death we don't want to plan
for it and we don't want to discuss it
with the most important people in our
lives I grew up in an Australian
community where people got old or sick
and passed away and only the adults
attended the funeral my parents would
come home looking sad and drained but
they didn't discuss it with us so I was
ignorant to death and of the grieving
process at 15 I got my invitation a dear
neighbor who was like an aunt to me died
suddenly of a heart attack and I
attended my first funeral and did my
first reading I didn't know the
tightness in my chest and the dryness in
my mouth was normal the celebrant got
some of the facts wrong and it made me
really angry he talked about how she
loved knitting knitting
he didn't mention that of 75 she still
made her own lawn built an amazing fish
pond in her front yard and made her own
ginger beer I'm pretty sure Kim knitter
isn't what she would have chosen for her
eulogy I believe if we discuss death as
part of day-to-day living we give
ourselves the opportunity to reflect on
our core values share them with our
loved ones and then our survivors can
make informed decisions without fear or
regret of having failed to honor a
legacy I am blessed to lead a wonderful
culturally diverse team and in the last
12 months we've lost five parents
including my own father and most
recently a former colleague who died at
41 from bowel cancer we started having
open and frank conversations about what
we were experiencing we talked about the
practical stuff the stuff no one
prepares you for dealing with government
agencies hospitals nursing homes advance
care directives funeral directors and
extended family members making decisions
about coffins headstones headstone
wording headstone font size all swoll
sleep-deprived
we also discussed some of the issues
triggered by our various cultural
backgrounds and we realize there can be
some significant differences and how we
honor the passing of a loved one a great
example of this is sorry business
practiced by Aboriginal and Torres
Strait Islander people during sorry
business family members will take on
specific roles and responsibilities
protocols such as limiting the use of
photographs saying the name of the
deceased and holding a smoking ceremony
are all a sign of respect and allow for
a peaceful transition of the spirit
these customs can be a complete contrast
to those we might practice in Western
cultures where would honor the memory of
a loved one by talking about them and
sharing photographs so my lesson from
this last year is life would be a lot
easier to live if we talked about death
now while we're healthy for most of us
we wait until we are too emotional to
ill or too physically exhausted and then
it's too late is it a time we started
taking ownership of our finale on this
earth so let's get going do you know
what you want when you die do you know
how you want to be remembered is
location important do you want to be
near the ocean or in the ocean do you
want a religious service or an informal
party or do you want to go out with a
bang literally in a firework when it
comes to death there's so much to
discuss but I want to focus on two
aspects why talking about and planning
your death can help you experience a
good death and then reduce the stress on
your loved ones and how talking about
death can help us support those who are
grieving so let's start with planning
how many of you have a will put your
hand up this is oh this is fantastic
in Australia 45% of adults over the age
of 18 do not have a legal will you're a
little bit above average this is a
startling statistic given that riding a
will can actually be quite simple and
inexpensive so I started asking my
friends and neighbors and was really
surprised to learn many of them don't
have a will and some couples don't
realize they need individual bills the
usual explanation was well it's all
going to go to my partner anyway so keep
in mind that laws vary from state to
state and country to country but this is
what happens in New South Wales if you
die without leaving a legal will firstly
a suitable administrator must be
appointed by the Supreme Court of New
South Wales chances are this is someone
who would never have met the deceased
that person isn't responsible for
arranging your funeral collecting assets
and distributing them after paying debts
and taxes and one of those debts will be
the bill for their services
this is not someone who would have known
you want the four-foot wooden giraffe in
your living room to go to the person who
helped you carry it halfway across the
world and yes that's in my will if you
die living a spouse or domestic partner
then chances are they will receive your
estate but if you are single it's far
more complicated as parents siblings
half siblings and dependents all come
into play and did you know that if you
make a regular donation to charity that
charity may have grounds to make a claim
on your estate the most important thing
to know is the bigger your estate but
more complicated that will will be and
the more expensive that bill so if you
don't have a will I asked you when else
in your life have you willingly given
money to the government when you didn't
have to I lost my father in February to
a progressive lung disease when Dad knew
his death was imminent he had three
clear wishes he wanted to die at home he
wanted to die surrounded by family and
he wanted to die peacefully not choking
or gasping for air and I'm pleased to
say that my family were able to support
dad's wishes and he achieved his goals
and in that sense he had a good death he
had the death he planned for because dad
wanted to die at home we had to have
some pretty tough conversations and fill
out a lot of paperwork the questions on
the forms cover everything from
resuscitation to organ donation
dad said take whatever organs you can
use this was upsetting to my mum as my
dad's health was deteriorating rapidly
and it was no longer at the right time
to talk about organ donation I believe
we need to discuss these issues when we
are fit and healthy so we can take the
emotion out of it and then we can learn
not just what is important but why it's
important so as part of my journey I
started engaging my family and friends
to find out their thoughts on death and
how they wanted to be remembered
I discovered you can host a death over
dinner or a deaf cafe which is a great
casual way to introduce the topic and
gain some wonderful insight did you know
that your body has to be legally
disposed of and though you can't just be
shoved off a cliff or set fire to in the
backyard in Australia you have three
options the two most common a burial and
cremation but you can also donate your
body to science and I am pleased to
report that innovation has touched the
world of corpse disposal you can now opt
for an eco funeral you can be buried at
the base of a tree in recycled cardboard
or a wicker basket and for those who
love the ocean there are eco-friendly
urns that will dissolve at sea
personally I plan to be cremated but
given that I get seasick I can think of
nothing worse than having my ashes flung
into a huge ocean swell I've actually
bought a plot in the Rose Garden next to
my dad I call up my investment property
but sadly there's no tax deduction so if
you plan for your death then your
survivors will know how to experience a
healthy bereavement without fear or
guilt of having failed to honor your
legacy as part of my research I've been
to seminars read books and talk to
palliative care nurses and I've come to
understand as a consequence of not
talking about death we don't know how to
be around grief and on the flip side if
we talk about death more we will become
more comfortable with the emotions we
experience around grief I discovered
this year it's actually a privilege to
help someone exit this life and although
in my heart is heavy with loss and
sadness
it is not heavy with regret I knew what
dad wanted and I feel at peace knowing I
could support his wishes my dad's last
24 hours are in a peaceful coma
and after days of around-the-clock care
we had time to sit hold his hand and say
goodbye he passed away on a Monday
morning just before breakfast and after
the doctor came and we waited for this
funeral home I went into the kitchen and
I ate a big bowl of perch when I told
some of my friends is so I really
shocked how could you eat at a time like
that
well I was hungry
you see grief impacted my sleep and my
ability to concentrate but it never
impacted my stomach I was always hungry
it's different for all of us and it's
really important that we acknowledge
that so if we don't talk about our death
and the death of loved ones how can we
possibly support a friend a colleague a
neighbor who is grieving how do we
support someone who has lost someone
suddenly like an accident or suicide we
tend to avoid them not because we don't
care because we go don't know what to
say we know as a friend we can't fix it
we can't take away that pain so we say
things to fill that awkward silence
sometimes things we regret saying
examples would be least he isn't
suffering anymore at least you've got
your memories at least you don't have to
pay the hospital parking anymore really
we don't need to say anything we just
need to be be patient be understanding
and be a listener and if you can't be
any of those things then please be the
person who makes lasagna the curry or
the casserole because your offerings
will be greatly appreciated I've been to
10 funerals in the last year one of
which I helped arrange they were in the
full gamut a very solemn Greek Orthodox
serve
for catholic requiem masses and a garden
party where i made a toast
while scattering my friend's ashes
around her garden with a soup ladle i
have carried kissed written on and
toasted coffins with a shot of ouzo I
have worn or black or color in a party
dress despite the vast differences in
send-off despite me being at times out
of my comfort zone doing something I've
never done before
I drew a comfort from one thing knowing
that this is what each person would have
wanted so what do I want well I like to
be organized so I have the will I'm a
registered organ donor and I have my
investment property all that is left is
planning my send-off a big party lots of
champagne color laughter and of course
music to remember me by thank you
[Applause]